hey this is ashwin my question is for
sam regarding customer discovery i saw
on a recent webinar that your calendar
was booked with dozens of calls each day
with potential customers for your new
product i'd like to know what kind of
questions you ask in those meetings and
how you use their feedback to influence
the business plan and product for your
new business thanks
[Music]
all right so the question was basically
the guy uh i did a uh like a little
small talk for like a private group and
i showed my calendar about how basically
on tuesdays and thursdays and whatever
like i'll i'll do like 10
maybe 10 or 13 like 10 to 20 minute
calls with customers
and
they asked what questions do i ask
and so i do a few things
the first thing is is if you haven't
read it there's this book called the mom
test
and it talks about like how to ask good
questions but i'm not asking questions
that a lot of people ask like would you
pay for this i don't ask that i don't
ask like would you use this i never
asked that stuff
so
in my case
or
all the time not just in my case but in
this particular case of this business
i'm starting but in all cases i'm not
even asking them if they want the
solution
that i'm saying is the solution to the
problem what i'm looking for is i'm
trying to get confirmation of does this
person have my problem the the problem
that i'm trying to solve and then i'm
trying to figure out well if they don't
have the problem are they even the
target market that i'm going after and
who
like what type of like archetype of
person uh demographic psychographic what
type of person consistently do i notice
has this problem and so i'll give you
some example questions
i can't find this client info have you
heard of hubspot hubspot is a crm
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases hubspot grow better
i don't want to talk too much about the
business that i'm starting because i'm
not ready to like reveal it yet but it
is working really well we've done a lot
we've done a lot in revenue in a very
short amount of time all from these
calls but i'll basically so i'm going to
use um
i'm just going to like use some vague
language so sorry about that but that's
what i'm going to do so i'll say
all right have you ever tried to use
uh blank before
oh you haven't but you've wanted to well
why haven't you
and they'll tell me answers like um
well you know just like no good one has
ever presented itself or the brands that
currently solve this they seem a little
old to me
they seem a little old school and i'll
say
tell me about that why do you think that
they seem old school to you why do you
think they seem archaic and not like new
and and and and they'll tell me they'll
tell me all these types of reasons and
so in my head i use that feedback to say
all right i get this constant pattern of
people saying a they want to use a
product like i'm offering but b they
haven't already because they um
none of the offerings like appeal to
them because they're not new and they
want something that's a little or
because they're all old and they want
something a little new looking so anyway
what i'm constantly doing on these calls
is i'm trying to get them to tell me if
they do or do not have the problem uh
that they're solved that i'm trying to
solve and so the second thing that i
then do is i try to close them and when
i close them i kind of typically get
them to sell me and so typically what
i'll do is
um
well this product if you used it how
much do you think it would help you
and oftentimes they'll tell me well it
would help me by doing x y and z and
i'll say to myself or i'll say to them
well how much value would that bring to
you like numerically like what type of
revenue what type of time would it save
you well if i joined one of these things
uh it would save me this much money and
this much time and it would help this
this and this and then at the end of the
call i say all right well look i'm
offering this i'm i'm solving this
problem i have a product already um in
the future i'm going to charge blank but
right now because you're early i'm going
to charge uh you know 500 which is like
a fraction of what the cost is
eventually going to be
if i if i can make all this happen are
you in you want to try it out and by the
way i'll refund your money entirely if
you're not interested and oftentimes
you'll say yeah i'm interested and then
i send them a link and typically i'm
able to close like 80 of people and so
on these calls the first half is i'm
just
discovery and i don't ever say
would you buy this i don't say any of
that i'm just asking really broad
open-ended questions to get them to
describe if they do or do not have the
problem that i'm solving for if they
don't have the problem then sometimes
i'll ask them why and that will kind of
indicate yes this is actually a problem
we're solving or no it's not but if they
do have the problem then i get to tell
them i get them to tell me how they've
tried to solve it in the past what has
worked and what hasn't and why they
aren't already using a solution
that exists then and then when they do
that they basically tell me
the um
the attributes that my my
solution should have in order to appeal
a customer like this person and then the
second half of the call of the last few
minutes sometimes i'll sell them and i i
try to get uh i want to close the deal
right there because if i get them in
then i can get feedback quicker and i
don't ever ask would you buy this i just
say oh well you said you wanted this i'm
offering this do you want it and if they
balk at it then i'm like well this isn't
really that big of a problem like this
isn't there's not that
big of a need here and so that's why i
try to sell them so anyway that's how i
do calls when i'm in the discovery phase
of a business i'll be on the call
uh different calls literally eight hours
a day and i think that's something that
people do that's not right which is they
don't get on the phone with potential
customers and they they don't spend
they'll do like one call a week at most
sometimes and i'm like no no no pack my
day i'm literally back to back to back
to back and i usually have a script and
i take notes and i
use this stupid headset that has like it
looks like a gamer's headset and a
microphone and i'm walking i go on walks
while i'm i'm doing this because it
helps me kind of
stay focused and be loose so anyway all
right that's one question today
[Music]
you